Now, before we jump into building levels, let's quickly talk about levels and what they are
as understanding this is very important.
So an Unreal Engine project is not made up of a single file, but rather a collection
of source code, content assets, plugins, configuration files, and other support files, right?
So one Unreal project is actually a collection of a bunch of different things.
Now in order to see what you interact with, we need a way to link all of these various
things together and that's where levels come in.
Levels allow us to add or spawn actors.
And these actors are what are used to help bring life to our creations.
Now when you are dealing with levels, there is this concept of a sub-level that would
be a level inside of a level.
And while this is possible, the main thing to take away from this is that no matter what
you are trying to display, you're always going to need some type of level in order to display
that information.
Now Unreal has a number of tools that make it easy when you create a new level.
So to make a new level, all we have to do is go to File, New Level, and this will invoke
the New Level Creation Wizard.
Then from there we can select any of the templates, Open World, Empty Open World, Basic, or Empty
Level, press Create, and we will have a new level created.